(dubstep music)
- [Voiceover] Jodhpur,
India is a sea of blue
in the middle of a hot, dry desert.
Welcome to the Blue City.
Jodhpur is the second largest city
in India's Rajasthan province.
Surrounded by a wall with bastions,
the striking blue buildings
in Jodhpur contrast sharply
and beautifully with the
neighboring Thar Desert.
It's the older quarters, built in 1459,
where many of the blue
buildings are found.
Some say the color is associated
closely with the Brahmans,
India's priestly caste,
and the blue houses
of the old city belong to
families of that caste.
There's also an argument that
termites are the real reason.
Builders added copper
sulfate to the whitewash
to thwart the pests,
which resulted in the eye-soothing blue.
However, locals say the blue
is a natural indigo dye.
A final explanation might
be the city's nickname.
It's known as the Sun City,
and the blue helps keep the homes cool.
Either way, Jodhpur looks
like a real life fairytale.
(calming electronic music)